when galaxies Collide it's a movie title
right there we need that one when you
say galaxies Collide is it that the
Galaxy's gravity affects another
Galaxy's gravity or are you looking at
actual objects hitting one another the
stars are so far apart that they almost
never hit each other directly so it's
like swarms of bees or Hornets you know
nests Wings rats through one another and
affecting one another from a distance
okay but uh a collision doesn't have to
happen only uh when a physical object
hits another physical object that what
you said the gravitational effect of one
object affecting the other is indeed as
much of a collision as we might think of
say two vehicles hitting one another or
something and so instead you get these
twists and turns you get bends you get
loops and whirls and it is all
gravitational